okay let's go to the phones at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
and see what is on people's minds oh
let's go to Brody from Dallas our friend
Brody from Dallas who has written the
guide on how to call into the show
what's going on Brody hey David I'm
pretty good how are you doing good
awesome hey so I know that Bernie
Sanders has asked his supporters as have
you spoken on your show about the proper
direction in which to go as far as
getting our police more accountable yes
our community safer and doing it in the
right way the question I have for you
today is when people who see that say
that look we've tried voting when you've
tried activism
we've tried legislative mechanisms we've
tried to digital mechanisms and now
that's works when people who come to you
and say hey David I think that using a
mechanism like a ballot initiative or
defunding to force people to come to the
table to negotiate for a different type
of Police Department is the way to go
what would your response be to that well
I I would reject on principle this idea
of we've tried it there has not been I
mean listen when you're talking about
police departments this has to do
primarily with with three things it has
to do with police chief's who are in
most places appointed by mayors so where
have been the big movements to hold
mayors accountable for who has been
selected as police chief I mean I'm sure
we can find some examples but there's
been no major movement to say elect
let's put in place the right mayor's
make police chief selection and police
policy a huge part of those mayoral
campaigns I've been involved from the
media side in a bunch of different
mayoral races and it's just it's just
never been a thing so then you've also
got a look at governor's because a lot
of funding for police is state funding
for both state and local police we
finally heard from Andrew Cuomo with
some ultimate
when it comes to police but I would just
reject the idea that we've quote tried
it now if we reject the idea that we
have tried it would that mean that if
there is a ballot initiative or a push
for a ballot initiative such as one that
for example is coming up where I am in
the area in Fort Worth to restrict a
portion of the funding that goes to Swat
and things like that would you support a
ballot initiative which it is on the bat
and I don't mean would you support it
one way or the other
would you support letting voters have a
say oh yeah of course I mean so there
there is a question as to whether you
want to vote on civil rights right so
when we talk about hey should gay
marriage be legal I am skeptical about
letting people vote on those things and
and people have voted the wrong way
when it comes to how tax money should be
used I am very much as a general rule in
favor of letting the people have a say
so while I don't think defund the police
is the solution if the public has said
we want this on the ballot then of
course that that it should be on the
ballot absolutely are there any other
mechanisms that you would suggest in
terms of the size of looking at
governors and who makes these
appointments that people can look at in
terms of making directly positive change
in their community yeah I mean I think
it's getting involved so when you talk
about lobbying city councilors I mean a
lot of people we have to turn the
internet activism into actually getting
involved in a local way because the
national movement around this is great
for energy but the national movement is
not going to make you know the Back Bay
neighborhood of Boston necessarily
demand or achieve change so I think it's
we've got to translate that in the same
way that like we've got to turn the
protests that started when Trump was
elected into voting in November if we
want to turn it into something we have
to take these protests and turn it into
a very very specific and calculated
local activism awesome well hey I
hopefully I lived up to the guide that I
created for calling in and I appreciate
the information and I love the show man
keep it up and thanks for all the hard
work dude
right Brody great to hear from you
always great to hear from Brody